welcome to this video playing gow poon
here from Russia I wonder i think i
played him many times before and is very
low rated for ya for whatever what I
remember about him I thought he had much
higher rating ok we play that old Indian
that went for a slightly an uncommon
line with d5 yeah it's a similar to the
sameish but what I'm like to prevent
some him playing an easy Bishop b5 at
some point night retreat and Bishop g5
is this a luxury I can afford Bishop d3
yeah probably first this move ok it
seems he he wants to really play b5
taking and play b5 ok
hmm yeah curious some nights e-form
threat or something I don't think so but
be three looks useful anyway to prepare
a form at some point yeah one offers
some ideas could be to play Bishop d8
Bishop b6 at some point exchange the
light squared Bishop this way I'd like
to open up the queenside I don't think
you can take because the Queen that
would be in an awful situation in the B
file and here i want to go night d12 be
too so that i have night c4 available
and I like this position so it looks
like white shirt and be comfortable with
this some additional space and possible
ideas on on the queenside but then okay
see people to play the Bishop to b6 and
where it's not so easy to accomplish
what i do i have i have a bad piece here
on the only to this is really a bad
piece
yeah maybe I can bring it to see form
but it's a very long way my ideas if he
removes the bishop the night on b6 let's
say he takes on c1 rook takes nite CH to
prepare should be six I have night c4
back or back as the wrong word but I can
play the Knight to c4 to prevent the
special p 6 and this I really want to
prevent don't want a bishop landing on
b6 what I'm trying to do is get the
night to d2 and night to see form so
Queen f 2 92 nite see for something like
this would be a nice improvement maybe
it's trying to play even each six and
Bishop g5 as possible
I I'd like to go here instead of f 2
because there's the bishop ah how
interesting this this idea of playing
Bishop b5 f5 is interesting no I didn't
want to spend more time if I can could
also consider to take or play player
direct meals like like that but I didn't
want to spend so much time here
want to do this pre move but it really
screws up the position the enter this
pre move it looks like I mean I'd down
or something okay I'm just to recapture
yeah
night you for some annoying to be new
but i can take these things okay can
take these six
yeah the sexist thing I couldn't take 26
because it could take d3 and the queen
is hanging so I needed to recapture
ok maybe a lazy move but I want to
prevent all these things going to reform
okay Queen f2 let's see that I can
exchange you finally
here you can try night f form sucking a
poem and push up at six but it's it's a
poem and i just take this you can't
check he can go to f6 but d6 it's a big
weakness yeah i don't even mind that
much I didn't see it that must admit
that but it's such a strong light on
c-46 hangs I cannot take it immediately
but it's it's a very nice position he
five is also a big big threat v5 takes
Queen g6 and it's its invasion time not
easy to play fine I'm not threatening on
d6 but but it's a constant very
interesting way to play that
so should I just play this a five or is
this too early
not sure that I'm threatenings so much
with this okay down on time ideas takes
Queen b6 which looks threatening but
it's not so clear what it's really is
threatening age 7 is just a shake check
probably threatens rook everyone and
then he's really animating net yeah it's
probably not so bad for me would so not
not clear as well if it is so dangerous
for them nobody's taking this time i
justjust take it I've rookie one rupee
seven stuff like that yeah my minor
pieces are really strong night on c4
mind the bishop
don't want to exchange Queens ready 26
Queenie for our moves
don't anyone f7
check
yeah age six is hanging and d6 is
hanging and g6 so lots of things hanging
oh I didn't see that but I can take him
I can take him I could have taken on a
date anyway I let's reconsider yeah yeah
I can take on a 80 didn't didn't see
that I just just think that that this
was my initial threat so I played it and
it's winning anyway but yeah it's even a
first mate the computer tells me but
it's a queen eight no yeah I simply
didn't see that the Queen covers it
right so nonsense but when winning
anyway yeah I'm not sure if this looked
like I overlooked this this Bishop g5
moved to be honest but it's still very
good for white because this is such an
such a nice configuration it's a
completely sealing the queenside the
night always puts this pressure on d6
and he has a hard time not defending d6
if he gives up this point for nothing I
will have those two great pawns and in
addition he's got the the kingside
weekend so this idea what I played is I
think really strong yeah he 5 the
computer the grease and gives why the
winning winning edge after a five it
wants to play rook see for now we had
this to this tells you that black is in
bad shape we should be eight is now its
choice takes eggs rookie one is the best
move for a nice i played a couple of
good ones here so the best movie about
rookie seven looks good but probably
around here we should be four RK as much
simpler but this is this as strong it is
strong get this gives up lots of the
advantage it says Queen f3 is stronger
we are Queen f3 also intending Queenie
formed this probably Bishop c6 as a good
move now yeah well I was on 30 seconds
and yeah I played a couple of good ones
of course I should should take here yeah
I think of interesting game thanks for
watching